that does not mean that feminism is a
Female Supremacy movement I think it is
feminism what's the definition what
definition do you give it the definition
well they talk about equality but they
don't mean it so
I don't mean it because
and Define it for the rest of women
everywhere when there's women out there
that are being abused when there's women
out there that have a higher chance of
domestic violence and you're going to
stand for majority in Leicester Square
where there's women passing by that are
probably in domestic proven uh
okay cut me off cut me off because I'm
making a good point cut me off I hope
you guys really keep going go ahead I
will keep going because I'm making a
good point that's why you don't want to
interrupt me yeah I hope you guys
honestly feel like you guys are
spreading a good message because all the
women out here aren't feeling that you
are okay I honestly really feel like you
guys are spreading a terrible message
and I'm so sorry that you feel this way
because feminism is not a Supremacy
movement